je vais moi je veux pas rentrer dans une
guerre des mots avec jean ça m'intéresse
pas je veux pas répondre
jean-marie le pen a éructé injurié tout
seul très bien il fera d'ailleurs 70
procès au front national comme il a
commencé à le faire très bien à personne
pour lui répondre
on n'est pas à ce niveau là moi j'suis
pas loin cour de récréation stratège du
fn vilipendé par jean marie le pen qu'il
accuse d'avoir orchestré la rupture avec
sa fille florian philippot suscite les
interrogations
son parcours du chevalement tisme au
marinisme intrigue sa discrétion aussi
malgré une présence quotidienne dans les
médias ainsi que son influence sur la
ligne politique actuelle du fn alors qui
est florian philippot quelle est sa
relation avec marine le pen
cette semaine des as bio en tout bien
tout honneur un numéro 2 qui a connu une
ascension fulgurante et qui nous a reçus
dans son bureau au siège du front
national
florian philippot bonjour un jour alors
vous êtes très présent dans les médias
avec marine le pen vous incarnez on va
dire l'image médiatique du fn pourtant
en préparant les missions on a visionné
beaucoup d'extraits et on a vu très peu
de moments où vous parlez de vous même
vous vous exprimer des choses plus
personnelles pourquoi oh c'est vraiment
une conception de l'engagement politique
c'est à dire qu'on m'a déjà posé la
question
bien sûr je considère qu' on est allé
dans une dérive notamment une sarkozy à
l'américaine on il a fallu exposer sa
vie privée
même en jouant sur jouer jusqu'à se
brûler parce que ça vous revient
toujours en boomerang et moi je
considère que ça n'est pas ça
l'engagement politique ce n'est pas ce
qui intéresse les français
justement la dignité de l'homme public
c'est d'être capable de préserver sa vie
privée et de mettre en avant ce qui
intéresse c'est à dire ça qu'on ses
convictions sa foi en la france sa foi
en la politique et son envie de
changement c'est ça que j'essaie de
faire passer
on n'y arrive pas toujours parce que
vous êtes malgré tout rattrapé par la
société actuelle alors ici il n'est pas
question de vie privée par contre il est
question de portraits sur la manière de
faire de la politique et c'est vrai
qu'on avait envie de mieux vous
connaître à ce moment on parle beaucoup
de vous de votre rôle de votre place
dans le parti de votre influence alors
voilà qui est florian philippot est bon
à savoir plus souvent par des extraits
des commentaires d'experts aussi on va
commencer avec olivier faye journaliste
au monde qui commence justement votre
discours est votre place au fn ça
commence avec une position qui a fait
beaucoup parler celle sur les victoires
en grand
de syriza a priori sur la plus proche de
mélenchon que du fn on regarde un
extrait sans commentaires et vous
réagissez
le grand débat en europe sur l'euro et
l'austérité et l'union européenne doit
passer par la victoire de syriza en
grèce alors oui je souhaite vivement la
victoire de syriza
en grèce le 25 janvier prochain je vous
le dis très clairement
l'extrême gauche grecque du parti series
a remporté hier les élections
législatives comment réagissez vous à
cette victoire je me réjouis de la gifle
démocratique monstrueuse que le peuple
grec vient d'administrer à l'union
européenne
marine le pen elle était sur cette ligne
la lune ni droite ni gauche avant de
connaître le haut niveau c'est sûr que
depuis qu'elle le connaît ça n'a fait
qu'amplifier fait complice ligne la fda
ont fini pour aujourd'hui au sein du
front national et des fonds cette ligne
nationale républicaine comme il dit et
c'est ça qui caractérise aujourd'hui en
grande partie la ligne du front national
en tout cas dans sa critique de l'union
européenne et aujourd'hui c'est quelque
chose qui est qui est assez décrié on a
vu l'a récemment il a aussi soutenu
podemos et ça a fait un peu tendu au
sein du front national on s'est dit
quand même soutien à l'estran gauche ça
passe mal voilà il ya quand même des
petites frictions sur le sujet et alors
ça fait grincer des dents mais du coup
parce que voilà l numéro deux très
écouté de marine le pen ça peut le
mettre en danger au contraire poussé
marine n'est pas la moins l'écouté je
pense pas florent filippi lui l'a
théorisé la chose c'est à dire qu'il se
dit que sa ligne politique sa ligne
économique
elle a permis au front national de
progresser électoralement donc temps que
ça fonctionne tant que ça marche
électoralement il n'a aucune raison de
s'estimer
menacée donc il a l'oreille de marine le
pen donc marine le pen est persuadé que
cette ligne là peut faire gagner le
front national il a aucune raison
d'avoir peur
effectivement par contre si prochaines
échéances ça ne fonctionne pas il sera
peut-être le premier à payer le prix de
d'éventuels échecs
ah oui c'est pas être les boucs
émissaires de l'échec en fait c'est ça
bah oui ce que bon il est en première
ligne
il apparaît comme la la la l'étendard la
figure de proue du front national dans
les médias et risque de payer le prix si
jamais ça ne fonctionne pas et pourtant
il n'est pas très aimé failli pourtant
ou peut-être conséquence il n'est pas
très aimé est ce qu'on a pu voir à lors
du dernier congrès il monte sur scène en
vainqueur
pourtant en cette première matinée de
congrès il sait déjà qu'il a perdue a
fait l'honneur de me faire confiance
eh bien il me faut faire un bilan de
cette stratégie et des nombreux succès
qu ensemble nous avons engrangés depuis
le souverainiste trop à gauche
la libérale trop à droite la nièce de
marine le pen face à son protégé
artisan avec elle de la dédiabolisation
du parti avant même l'ouverture du
congrès et les résultats ont fuité dans
la presse
marion maréchal-le pen est arrivé en
tête du vote des militants
florian philippot n'est que quatrième
mais sous le regard des journalistes
marine le pen lui apporte un soutien
appuyé
cet adhérent sur dix 13 autres allons à
8 survie c'est encore mieux j ai un sur
sa proximité avec marine le pen est ce
qu on voit bien que là elle
n'encourageait sous l'oeil des caméras
comment vous analysez leurs relations
parait-il le soir où ils se sont
rencontrés par l'intermédiaire de paul
marie coûteaux ils ont eu un coup de
foudre amical un coup de foudre
intellectuelle
l'un à l'infini c'est les phrases de
l'autre voilà c'était une relation
complètement fluide donc bon je pense
qu'il ya une relation amicale évidente
voilà qui a faim aussi faciliter les
choses
ensuite ils ont dû se retrouver sur leur
analyse de la crise française de la
crise européenne
et ensuite ça a découlé sur le programme
mis en place a mis en place par marine
le pen
je pense que l'effectif n'y a jamais eu
une personne qui a eu tes aussi à la
fois aussi proche qui est autant
d'importance auprès de marine le pen
jamais une personne n'a eu autant
d'importance dit-il auprès de marine le
pen vous répondez quoi ça vous inspire
quel commentaire
il ya plusieurs choses parce qu'il ya du
fond et à l'arrière un retour sur le
congrès j'étais un peu passé ça me
rappel de quelques souvenirs de question
médiatique ya quelques mois on est un
peu passé ailleurs je me suis pas du
tout senti désavoué je vous le dis par
le vote des adhérents parce que je sais
comment ça fonctionne un congrès en
interne
j'étais quatrième avec 70 % des voix ce
qui est très bon parce que si vous
voulez en interne ce sont des adhérents
qui vote qui ont l'habitude de voter et
qui votent pour ceux qui sont peut-être
là depuis plus longtemps
c'est vrai vous êtes là depuis moins
longtemps mais je suis là depuis bien
longtemps
je vais tenter de rester en moins de
respect beaucoup je suis tourner dans
les fédérations mais j'ai fait moins de
réunions publiques que les personnes qui
étaient peut-être devant moi j'avais pas
le nom le pen qui a capturé des au delà
de ses talents personnels que je ne nie
évidemment pas mais qui a pu aider mario
qui était la seule candidate aux congés
qui avait le nom le pen donc ça si vous
voulez pour moi je le prends comme au
contraire un soutien sur la relation
avec marine le pen
voilà oui parce que c'est ça c'est ça
ses intérêts alors effectivement je
réalise du monde disait j'ai rencontré
en 2009 ça s'est tout de suite bien
passé c'est le rêve ça s'est bien passé
d'abord parce que on est ce comme on dit
sur la même longueur d'onde politique on
est lent partage vraiment les mêmes
convictions la même manière d'analyser
les choses de voir les choses
ça facilite le travail cette espèce de
symbiose politique se c'est une symbiose
aussi intellectuel et plus
sinon ça fonctionne pas il ya aussi ce
petit plus ces atomes crochus personnel
amicaux qui font que humains qui font
qu'on s'entend bien et qu'on a une
confiance je crois réciproque qui est
qui est très forte qui se dément pas et
on s'entend bien
si fait que dans la vie même quand on
parle pas politique on rit on
on plaisante ensemble agissent ensemble
pour la musique des années 80 j'ai voté
oui on peut écouter ensemble du jeanne
mas ou où on peut aussi regarder
ensemble des thrillers ou en tout cas
pas seul ce que les conseillers pas
forcément les regardent ensemble n'a pas
beaucoup le temps parce qu'on on partage
une passion commune aussi pour ce type
de cinéma
mais bon ça c'est autre chose après sur
le fond là l'histoire de syriza et
podemos je sais très bien et je les dis
aussi que nous ne partageons pas du tout
la même vision de ces partis par exemple
sur l'immigration d'accord mais ça c'est
une évidence
ce qui nous intéresse politiquement dans
la victoire notamment césar tongs et
l'europe
est-ce qu'on n'a pas eu raison est ce
que 2 grâce à la victoire de syriza
depuis janvier on ne parle pas de
l'europe de l'euro des politiques
d'austérité et du problème démocratique
que pose l'union européenne si syriza
n'avait pas gagné on parlerait pas que
tout cela il y aurait une chape de plomb
et les registres exactement l'analyse
qu'on a fait là est alors pour revenir
justement parce que vous dites oui vous
vous êtes retrouvé en fait avec marine
le pen sur cette analyse de ce que
serait qu'on s'interroge sur comment
vous fonctionnez n ya pas longtemps il y
avait un documentaire alors c'était sur
françois hollande et manuel valls 1 qui
expliqué qu'ils s'envoyaient des petits
sms le soir le matin pour débriefer
c'est vrai qu'on s'interroge sur comment
ce genre de décision on a pris l'exemple
de syriza se prennent quoi est-ce que
vous en avez parlé ensemble c'est vous
qui avez eu l'idée c'est elle c'est vrai
que voilà c'est c'est quelque chose qui
peut paraître assez atypique du coup
comme type de positionnement donc on
s'interroge sur comment ça se décide ce
genre de choses voilà déjà il ya les
instances au front pour décider il ya un
bureau exécutif il ya un bureau
politique cela que les débats n'ont pas
même sur ces genres de choses alors sur
ce genre de choses où c'est parfois ça
arrive rapidement parce qu'à une soirée
électorale en grèce le dimanche et qu'on
a tous les deux par exemple matinale le
lundi bon on s'appelle on discute mais
met par exemple sur ces visas on est
tombés tout de suite exactement sur la
même analyse et concernant marine le pen
alors vous l'avez rencontré donc en 2009
lors d'un dîner c'est ça un après yo
landi n'est assez vite voilà un dîner
vous n'étiez pas à l'époque on y
reviendra sur votre parcours un petit
peu plus tard
du tout vous n'avez jamais voté les
flammes c'est ce que vous aviez vous
aviez dit comment ça s'est passé c'est
vous qui vouliez la rencontre et c'est
vous vous étiez jeu depuis quelques
temps déjà
moi j'avais découvert comme tous les
français marine à travers les médias
bien sûr je la trouvais brillante sur
une ligne qui me plaisait notamment son
analyse de la mondialisation de la
souveraineté nationale et j'ai eu
l'opportunité effectivement de la
rencontre et ce qui s'est fait un peu de
temps après que je sente de l'ena en
voilà et puis ça a collé et puis on a
commencé à travailler tout de suite
moi j'étais d'abord comme j'étais encore
au ministère de l'intérieur comme je dis
je fais des conférences j'ai fait une
conférence de presse quasiment burqa bon
j'avais quelques pseudo enfin pas grand
chose et u23 article et ensuite
et libération j'ai pu me mettre en
disponibilité delà de la fonction
publique comme il se doit
et puis je suis entré dans la campagne
présidentielle de marine le pen comme
directeur stratégique en 2011 voit la mi
octobre 2011 parce qu'elle me l'avait
proposé
voilà j'ai estimé que c'était une chance
et que ça ne se refusait pas et vous
avez hésité parce qu'on imagine enfin on
essaye de se mettre à votre place voilà
2009 vous rencontrez de marine le pen
puis ça va très vite
vous avez d hésitation parce que quand
même à l'époque le fn c'est parce que
c'est aujourd'hui et jean marie le pen
qui extraient présent même si marine le
pen a pris la tête du parti vous vous
vous hésitez pas j'avoue honnêtement je
peux faire une réponse politiquement
correct en dix ans
j'ai forcément hésiter c'est une
décision lourde il faut réfléchir etc
je peux vous dire la vérité et la vérité
bien sûr qu'on réfléchisse mais en même
temps quand on a tellement envie d'aider
une personne et de se mettre au service
de ses convictions
quand vous êtes vous avez l'opportunité
dans votre vie de faire ce qu'il vous
plaît ce qui vous tient à coeur c'est
vraiment le combat pour la france
mais depuis très longtemps il avait eu
téléphone un verre avec le général de
gaulle et c'est reparti
un cadeau de militants pour le coin car
moselle en général de gaulle avec un
voile à pardon c'était pour la
parenthèse france tout arrive blanc bien
que lui aussi grincer des dents au fn
d'ailleurs paraît-il et j'entends du
message entend pas non mais mais si vous
voulez voilà donc donc vous y allez vous
avez l'opportunité de faire ce que de
défendre vos idées c'est pas donné à
tout le monde d'être au service d'une
personne que vous admirez pas vous y
allez maintenant j'ai pas j'ai pas
regretter je ne regrette pas alors sur
sur la place votre place dans au sein du
parti
c'est aussi beaucoup lié à justement
vous avez parlé ce coup de foudre amical
à vous avez un peu confirmer ce qu'ils
expliquent très vite je sais pas si vous
finissiez les phrases les indés l'un de
l'autre
c'est de la romance c'est de la romance
montre en tout cas tout de suite vous
accrocher très bien vous êtes sûr vous
partager à une analyse politique aussi
c'est vécu comme en interne ça parce que
forcément on et ça suscite des têtes des
jalousies non bah on en interne d'abord
c'est pas trop vécu parce que j'ai
vraiment départ une relation avec marine
le pen et quelques personnes de son
entourage proche
donc je suis pas dans les instances du
mouvement moi je rentre au front 2011
donc pendant deux ans vous êtes un peu
dans l'ombre bah je rencontre quelques
personnes voilà il m'arrive de venir au
siège etc
mais je suis pas véritablement intégrée
dans le mouvement dans l'appareil c'est
quand j'arrive en 2011 que je vraiment
je m'intègre au front national je rentre
au bureau politique je suis directeur
stratégique de sa campagne
présidentielle
louis aliot et directeur technique
voilà et la bomba je suis totalement
intégré je me présente pour la première
fois des élections c'est aux
législatives en 2012
je fais 46 et demi pour cent des voix
puis je suis nommé vice président en
juillet 2012 du front national et ces
jeux constituent mes équipes je suis élu
enfin députés européens 2014 tout ça
c'est un chemin par le front par les
électeurs je moi je voulais je j'ai le
sentiment que le front c'était un parti
mouvement qui laisser sa chance à la
méritocratie voilà alors je dis pas qui
a pas eu forcément quelques il peut y
avoir des jalousies parce que la
télévision rend fou ce qui ne passe pas
parfois ce qu'il passe aussi quand ils
prennent la grosse tête mais dieu merci
c'est pas mon cas mais ça rend fou aussi
ce qui ne passe pas ça peut arriver
donc je dis pas que tout les forcément
facile et formidable on a une communauté
humaine mais en même temps je dois dire
que j'ai été très bien accueilli par les
cadres par les fédérations que je suis
invité toutes les semaines dans les
fédérations que mes débuts électoraux je
pense ont été très bons et et que
je me suis fait ma place avec marine
mais maintenant aussi avec toute une
équipe avec toute une équipe et un vous
dites ça rend fou ce qu'ils n'y passe
pas ça peut ça peut certains c'est vrai
que vous êtes je l' ai dit en
introduction effectivement très présent
avec marine le pen vous êtes un peu les
deux plus médiatique alors qu'à d'autres
personnes au front national vous pas
relayé par exemple de louis aliot
comment ça se fait que c'est c'est vous
puisque les autres c'est un choix
stratégique du parti c'est les
journalistes c'est parce que voilà pour
défendre la ligne c'est plus facile que
ce soit toujours les mâles non alors
maintenant c'est pas le front national
qui décide qui l'envoie dans les médias
sont les médias qui invite alors il ya
parfois un phénomène pervers qu'on
invite ceux qui sont qui ont déjà une
notoriété c'est que c'est très compliqué
de faire entrer quelqu'un dans la
machine on arrive de temps en temps moi
je suis assez alti du convoi pas mal ces
derniers temps comme quelqu'un comme
david rachline on le voit comme nicolas
bay comme stéphane ravier qu'on a réussi
à faire avancer bon très bien d'accord
donc vous dites il peut y avoir des
jalousies là dessus mais c'est
essentiellement là dessus que ça porte
finalement aujourd'hui font reviendra
après sûr sûr sûr qu'elle que je n'ai
pas de souhaits dans un jour d'hui dans
un à ce panier de crabes où il y aurait
des ressentiments des jalousies des
croche patte
honnêtement ce serait ça je serais parti
plutôt le sentiment d'être dans une
communauté militante qui se bat pour la
france qui se bat pour des idées et
après on est une communauté humaine donc
on a nos petits une optima de temps en
temps mais c'est pas très grave tout ça
pour protéger le dj jamais regretté
d'avoir voilà travailler avec marine le
pen et d'avoir adhéré au front national
on se souvient que paul marie coûteaux
qui vous a présenté est parti un du
rassemblement bleu marine en 2014 en
dénonçant l' influence du père devant le
call at il dit la fille cède toujours
alors c'était avant la rupture
évidemment c'était en 2014
mais est-ce qu'il ya eu des moments où
vous avez eu la même analyse que lui
avant on parle de avant l'époque d'avant
il ya eu en fin de période avant
les événements que vous connaissez
récents sur jean marie le pen une
accumulation de sa part effectivement de
polémiques de propos de phrases
choquantes très éloigné de la ligne
républicaine patriotes du mouvement et
s'il ya eu là four mais bon tout ce que
vous connaissez
patrick mallet la fournée en 2014 sa
suite et je dirais ça devenait de plus
en plus fréquent est effectivement là il
y avait un phénomène pour tout le monde
je crois de saturation un phénomène de
saturation mais qui concernait aussi de
plus en plus nos militants sur le
terrain parce que quand vous avez ce
genre de phrase
bon j'ai prononcé à la télévision dans
un article de journal
mais le lendemain c'est pas vous qui
allez sur le terrain c'est le militant
c'est le candidat et lui je trouve
physiquement face à des gens sur un
marché qui lui disent assez légitimement
mais votre président d'honneur il vient
de sortir une horreur sur les chambres à
gaz où je ne sais quoi qu'est ce que
vous faites qu'est ce que vous dites
pourquoi je vais voter pour vous est-ce
que vous cautionnez ça il faut penser
aux militants il se retrouvait dans ces
situations concrètes sur le terrain
donc il y avait ce phénomène de
saturation skin aunis qui n'enlève pas
tout ce qu'on doit à jean marie le pen
qui a fondé les derniers mois ça
devenait compliqué d'accord il y en a qu
il faut être honnête et lui penser par
exemple paul marie coûteaux elle cède
toujours vous vous êtes dit ça
la preuve que non ouais ouais d'accord
dont ceux qui sont partis au coin
wiltord ou c'est elle qui a changé qui
finalement s'est ressaisi face à des
menaces de départ elle était allée
devenu déjà présidente du front puis je
pense qu'elle a espéré qu'il prenne que
jean marie le pen prenne sa place de
président d'honneur comme un honneur
justement est comme une forme de sagesse
ça aurait pu être ça mais en dehors de
l'action politique
voilà surtout provocante mais ça a été
son choix il a décidé au contraire
d'être de plus en plus présent elle a
fini par prendre évidemment ses
responsabilités politiques
avec toutes les difficultés qu'on
imagine personnel faire je sais qu'il ya
une souffrance personnelle message
d'hier c'était bien elle ne l'affichent
pas ne létale pas elle ne l'a pas et
allait elle a fait le choix de la pudeur
je pense que ça l'honore salle a grandi
on viendra un petit peu plus tard sur
sur un ou deux points concernant ce
départ mais d'abord votre parcours on va
continuer donc vous avez parlé de votre
rencontre avec marine le pen directeur
stratégique de sa campagne en 2012
c'est à ce moment là donc fin 2011 que
marine le pen vous présente
officiellement aux français et aux
médias on revoit quelques images
commentées par le politologue jean yves
camus une direction
raté gic que j'ai confiée à florian
philippot c'est donc ce nordiste le haut
fonctionnaire mystérieux que marine le
pen a finalement dévoilé début octobre
lors de la présentation de son équipe de
campagne
florian philippot 29 ans diplômé de hec
et de l'ena est inspecteur de
l'administration au ministère de
l'intérieur bref une grosse tête et un
haut fonctionnaire qui s'est mis en
disponibilité pour devenir le stratège
de la campagne présidentielle de marine
le pen
si la côtoie depuis plus de deux ans son
adhésion au fn ne date que de septembre
quant à son engagement politique
il a commencé à gauche en soutien à jean
pierre chevènement candidat en 2002
alors déjà qui viennent si je viens de
chez jean pierre chevènement
mettons les choses alors juste hauteur
il vient très exactement d'un tout petit
comité de soutien à la candidature
présidentielle de jean pierre
chevènement comité qui était composé
semble-t-il de deux étudiants la
chaussée ce qui évidemment est mieux que
rien mais ne confère quand même pas une
proximité avec jean pierre chevènement
qui est avéré c'est le moins qu'on
puisse dire
il y avoue front national ou plus
exactement rassemblement bleu marine
quelques personnes qui ont été plus
proches de jean-pierre chevènement que
lui ville natif de croix lycéens marcq
en baroeul florian philippot est devenu
parisien même s'il revient souvent dans
le nord
voir sa famille si vous faites le
cocktail de tous ces ingrédients la
jeunesse c'est l'engagement aux côtés de
jean pierre chevènement le parcours
universitaire les origines sociales donc
la méritocratie cette manière de
conjuguer aussi le goût de la nation et
l'appel aux classes populaires
le cocktail est parfait c'est
précisément ce dont à un moment donné
marine le pen a besoin et qui doit
permettre de combler le déficit de crise
de crédibilité problème je ne crois pas
au clivage gauche droite
voilà je n'y ai jamais cru et c'est vrai
que jean pierre chevènement exprimer une
pensée très républicaine un discours
très ferme très clair lui aussi le
rétablissement de l'autorité de l'état
qui m'a semblé à l'époque très cohérent
c'est vrai c'est en 2002 j'avais 20 ans
alors j'ai fait campagne pour lui
j'étais à chaud avec les petits moyens
et puis il m'a semblé qu'aujourd'hui
c'est marine le pen qui exprime le mieux
cette même cohérence avec beaucoup plus
d'efficacité puisqu'elle fait des scores
bien supérieurs à ceux de jean pierre
chevènement bien sûr sa culture aux
fonctionnaires de surcroît du ministère
de l'intérieur fait de lui quelqu'un qui
est tout le temps dans les éléments de
langage et dans le discours normé alors
c'est précisément là un travers que le
chevènementiste juste titre à mon avis
dénoncé donc on a beaucoup de mal à voir
ce que pensent réellement l'individu
florian philippot qui disparaît
totalement face à la fonction florian
philippot voilà c'est ça qui est le plus
curieux aussi qu'il n'ya pas on ne voit
pas d'aspérités est en tout cas pour les
électeurs visiblement ça leur manque et
c'est ce qui fait aussi la peut-être la
seule faiblesse de florian philippot
sait qu'il lui sera difficile à terme
mais évidemment à son âge toutes les
évolutions sont possibles de rester
aussi distant vis-à-vis de l'électorat
avec qui ne semble pas avoir une immense
en pâtit lorsqu'il est en campagne
voilà l'homme disparaît vers la fonction
vous commenterez évidemment vous me
direz mais d'abord sur le parcours vous
avez réagi à plusieurs reprises un sur
chevènement en disant j'ai jamais dit le
contraire c'est un truc monté en épingle
par les médias mais finalement moi je
crois avoir toujours été très clair j'ai
pas surestimer mon rôle j'étais en
première année de la chaussée j'étais
militant très actif
j'ai fait tous les meetings j'étais à
son qg de campagne le 21 avril à gérard
organisé un dîner débat que max gallo
qui est une figure de son comité de
soutien je l'invitais sur le campus
lui-même chevènement un an plus tard en
2003 d' hec et des militants j'étais pas
dans l'état major et j'ai jamais dit le
contraire
on trouvera jamais une déclaration donc
je n'ai pas surestimer mon rôle mais
c'est vrai que sa campagne
enfin son discours mme me plaisait son
courage politique en sip aussi trois
démissions de ministres
un ministre ça ferme sa gueule ou ça
démissionne il a démissionné
n'at il voulait pas fermer sa gueule je
pense qu'ils avaient raison c'était
trois démissions de fond c'était pas des
démissions sur des comptes cachés en
suisse où voilà d'autres horreurs
c'était célèbre émission sur des sujets
de fond je regrette son évolution que je
trouve pas tout à fait à la hauteur du
personnage mais c'est un autre débat
la fin me fait un peu rire enfin bon
après chacun juge cha cha cha cun juge
une personne comme il l'entend ce que
pense laurent philippot l'homme par
rapport à flash philippot la fonction
ils pensent la même chose
je suis désolé il ya peut-être qu'il ya
sûrement effectivement beaucoup de
responsables politiques qui disent à peu
près linverse de ce qu'ils pensent
réellement quand ils sont sur les
plateaux dans les hémicycles
moi quand je suis au parlement européen
au courant je suis à la radio à la
télévision dans une réunion publique
avec mes amis dans toutes les régions de
france jeudi à exactement la même chose
donc je n'y a pas de différence
quant à sa difficulté avec les lecteurs
comme il dit mais où
enfin j'ai fait sept cent mille voix aux
élections européennes deuxième score de
france 29 % des voix au candidat aux
régionales ce sera le cas je serai
candidat en général et aux listes est si
elle est je suis présenté pour la
première fois la conscription de moselle
où on avait fait 7 % en 2007 et j'ai
éliminé le député sortant j'ai fait 46
et demi pour cent des voix dont vous
souhaitez pas vous n'avez pas
l'impression parce qu'on entend parfois
vous avez un côté assez
non juste un haïtien je suis seule exit
donc que le type qui va aller boire un
coup ou taper sur l'épaule
et voilà c'est ça une campagne je sais
faire une campagne mais il faut le faire
avec sincérité faut pas rentrer mais les
gens c'est que les gens sont idiots
parce que vous allez leur taper dans le
dos leur dire elle est tournée générale
mais derrière il ya rien et que ça
marche pas ça moi quand quelqu'un me
parle dans un bar ou dans la rue ou dans
un marché et je suis en campagne je
l'écouté et je m'intéresse à ce qu'il
dit et ce qu'ils pensent bon voilà c'est
ma manière de faire donc vous avez envie
de continuer en tout cas vous me semblez
vous vous sentez à l'aise et vous vous
sentez à l'aise sur le terrain n'a pas
progressé s'améliorer s'amender écouter
des conseils bienvenu bien sûr voilà
j'espère que je vais y avait là oui mais
oui mais j'espère que je vais continuer
de progresser il faut de toute façon
progressé mais c'est vrai que ce qui
alors ce qu'on a entendu lorsque
préparant les missions discuter un peu
avec les uns et les autres qui disent
victimes en faisant philippot même les
journalistes ou là les gens ont
l'impression que vous êtes vraiment
souvent sur la sur la réserve quoi voilà
il n'y a pas de off avec vous on boit un
café avec vous on n'a pas tout à coup
plein de choses qui sortent voilà c'est
parfois là vous êtes peut-être très
sollicités pour les plateaux télé mais
pour l'off beaucoup moi sommes très
prudents on a l'impression c'est
peut-être ça aussi qui veut de la presse
écrite est pas fana de dans deux cafés
avec moi ou d'entretien pas ce que je
fais pas beaucoup de huf
parce que souvent les offres j'aime pas
trop parce que les hommes c'est souvent
à laisser taper sur le voisin pas se
mentir c'est ça un off
la plupart du temps à s'essayer
d'aiguiller les journalistes et leur
donner des petits mais quand on a un
petit message à faire peur ça peut être
pratique et ça vous avait pas de message
à faire passer en interne
je suis j'en ai je vais voir la personne
en interne les affaires internes les
bisbilles internes tel ou tel parti
honnêtement je trouve que sa distance il
aux citoyens de l'élection au faux final
c'est amusant ça fait du buzz ça fait
tout ce qu'on veut c'est au final sacré
d'abstention sadc
je crois fondamentalement et alors il ya
aussi autre chose peut-être dans ce
qu'il dit sur le côté l'homme philippot
la fonction c'est un peu les aspérités
c'est vrai qu'à un moment et tous les
politiques ne font un moment voilà
arrivés à un certain stade de leur
parcours
voilà d'essayer de montrer un peu
l'homme derrière voilà la fonction mais
marine le pen n'avait fait aussi
d'ailleurs on se souvient en 2006 de son
de son livre où elle parlait justement
de ses relations avec son père de ce
qu'elle pense et voilà d'aller un peu
parler de soi pour raconter des choses
pour que les gens vous
vous saisissent mais est ce que c'est
important et si oui qu'est ce que vous
auriez moi je voulais j'ai eu une chance
incroyable je suis ironique c'est que
j'ai une presse qu'il a fait pour moi
une presse people qu'il l'a fait pour
moi si vous voulez donc avec en plus les
images longueuil est donc bon donc point
de vue vie privée j'ai été servi pour le
reste pour le reste encore une fois
marine le pen dans un cas un peu
particulier le président de son
mouvement était son père donc on
comprend quelque chose à dire mais je
pense que c'est plutôt une femme
politique qui a toujours été aussi par
rapport à des sarkozy ou d'autres ou
dévalent sur la réserve est plutôt sur
cette séparation stricte entre privé et
public je pense que c'est aussi son
tempérament et sa manière d'aborder la
politique mais moi faire un livre bien
sûr je je n'exclus absolument pas de
faire un livre j'en ferai peut-être un
et même plusieurs
parce que j'ai les choses probablement à
dire alors on mêle à la politique et le
parcours humain bien sûr mais ce ne sera
pas un livre autobiographique
certainement pas mais vous comprenez
toutes ces questions sur vous parce que
c'est vrai qu'il ya eu d'ailleurs des
papiers dans la presse alors
effectivement entre chevènement et
marine le pen ces questions le côté
voilà vous avez surgit très vite ça
suscite plein plein de questions voilà
donc on a un côté un peu peut-être vingt
quatre igual a peut-être un des
fantasmes du coup sûr votre influence
votre rôle vous avez juste un truc
classique en politique mais enfin je
pense avoir répondu à un passage de
chevènement à marina c'est vrai que si
on a des grosses lunettes style années
gauche droite guerre froide il ya un
fossé irréconciliables entre la gauche
et la droite on n'y comprend rien si on
regarde sincèrement le fond le fond des
idées
le patriotisme la souveraineté nationale
sont descendus à droite un chevènement
bien sûr le l'autorité l'ordre
républicain la laïcité bon il ya des
différences bien sûr mais je veux dire
le socle commun je pense que honnêtement
elle et chevènement aujourd'hui s'il dit
ce qu'il pense vraiment et beaucoup plus
proche de marine le pen que françois
hollande il n'aimera pas que je dise ça
mais je le dis parce que je le sais et
je le pense et ce n'est pas insultant
que je lui fais au contraire jean pierre
chevènement il n'est pas européiste
fédéraliste
l'immigrationnisme c'est à ça n'est pas
jean pierre chevènement je pense qu'il
le sait je veux pas le prétend que je
connais mieux chevènement que
chevènement lui-même mais je connais je
connais quoi il a essayé de peser mais
je les écoute et je pense savoir ce qui
conduit sans très loin du fn aussi sur
pas mal de sujets principaux mal de
questions et pas du tout selon lui a
jamais demandé de rejoindre le front
national
mais au moins je veux dire d'être une
voix qui défend des idées de fond et
qu'il arrête peut-être aussi de la
diabolisation ça n'a pas de sens alors
si on parle beaucoup de vous en ce
moment je les ai dit tout à l'heure
c'est c'est aussi parce que voilà vous
avez joué un rôle paraît-il d'ailleurs
ça nourrit peut-être aussi toutes les
interrogations
au moment de la mise à l'écart de jean
marie le pen
alors pour se remettre dans le bain
aussi pour vous interroger sur peut-être
un fameux de suite je vous propose de
voir lequel je vous propose de revoir un
petit montage de quelques déclarations
de jean-marie le pen commenté toujours
par olivier faille
je dois dire que j'ai honte ce que le
président de la présidente du front
national porte mon nom et je
souhaiterais d'ailleurs qu'elle le
perdent le plus rapidement possible elle
peut le faire soit en se mariant avec
son concubin soit peut-être avec
monsieur philippe on en voit très bien
que monsieur b nippon s'empare des
leviers de commande place ses hommes
c'est mignon partout et gilles fait une
pression constante évidemment sur marine
le pen et le pont bureau politique
tout se finit priam à tallinn et la
rupture est totale et définitive
alors que madame le pen disait qu'une
thalys est que de refuser la
l'investiture pour l'élection régionale
il y avait déjà deux taux de taurine à
les inquiéter
toi le premier avant rien twitts de
cette nature là c'est louis aliot c'est
louis aliot qui en premier a dit que
voilà il y avait 1
divorce une rupture de nature
irréconciliables quels sont les termes
exacts dans ce conflit là c'est évident
que j'ai enfilé pourra jouer à jouer à
peser de tout son poids qu'elle a
enchaîné je crois a dit qu'il avait même
mis sa démission dans la balance
certains disent que c'est le cas
d'autres lui l'unique c'est qu'il ait
fait ça l'art est il relate il a dit si
jamais tu n'es pas à démarrer la peine
si jamais tu n'es pas sévère avec ton
père plein de cadres vont partir vont
quitter le parti
tout cas lui il était persuadé que ce
moment-là devait arriver que le moment
de rupture avec le père devait arriver
et que ce moment là est décisif pour la
conquête du pouvoir est ce qui est
intéressant dans ce que vous dites c'est
que y'a eu louis aliot a effectivement
le compagnon de marine le pen qui a
envoyé se fit sur la rupture avant lui
et pourtant c'est lui que jean marie le
pen cible dans toutes ces attaques
pourquoi dans ces cas là jean marie le
pen se polarise style sur lui parce que
jean marie le pen c'est un fin politique
il n a compris qu'il y avait un coin
enfoncé que ce coin cet effet un filippo
parce que phalange philippot suscite une
certaine défiance au sein du fn et donc
voilà jean marie le pen sait très bien
que voilà le lieu le lien de faibles
enfin voilà en quelque sorte c'est c'est
florian philippot est ce que philippe oc
légitimité il attire de sa relation avec
marine le pen
s'il y avait plus ça qu'est-ce qui
pourrait devenir ça on ne sait pas voilà
vous êtes alors c'est vrai qu'il ya eu
ce fameux tweet dans mon entend
d'ailleurs jean marie le pen qui ont par
l'unss et florian philippot qui a été
beaucoup plus dur puisque vous pas vous
avez parlé de rupture totale et
définitive un le jour même où marine le
pen
sortez un communiqué effectivement à dix
ans quel s'opposer à l'investiture de
son père aux régionales mais 100 en est
que des décisions seraient prises mais
elles étaient moins dur que vous alors
déjà peut-être
pourquoi pourquoi ce tweet pourquoi être
allé aussi loin et aussi vite par
rapport à ce que faisait marine le pen
qui pesait justement un communiqué
qu'ils sortaient un communiqué marine je
pense a été dans son rôle totalement
nous envoie là il peut pas avoir
l'investiture en paca et d un bureau
exécutif sera réunie je ne laisserai pas
le mouvement être mis en danger par la
police par les déclarations jean marie
le pen son attitude et c'est bon moi à
titre personnel je dit à peu près la
même chose mais chacun ses mots est
totale et définitive à un bureau de
massy volets bleus au mans
quand on parle du détail les chambres à
gaz pétain réhabilité on peut comprendre
les attaques contre la démocratie etc
soufflerie neige etc ont assumé congrès
a su mme bah oui rupture totale et
définitive c'est pas manning c'est pas
mon combat c'est pas ma vision des
choses et je ne peux pas dire autre
chose je ne me sentais plus en
communauté militante avec jean marie le
pen à venir christophe est ce que ce qui
a été dit aussi des relents avez vous
été clair les jambons
il attend de la clarté on condamne
points on n'est pas d'accord et la
rupture est totale et définitive
ou alors on est à moitié d'accord mais
il faut le dire aussi marine le pen
n'était pas d'accord avec n'était pas
d'accord il faut il faut vous savez
personne
personne ne m'a reproché ce tweet au
contraire je pense qu'on aime bien la
clarté les gens qui votent pour nous les
militants qui se battent pour le front
et leurs idées
les candidats qui se présentent parfois
pas facile pour leur carrière exactement
qu'ils étaient contents que ce soit dit
m david moyes par date pour qu'on arrive
au pouvoir ils en ont marre de voir la
france dans cet état là et ils
n'accepteront pas qu'on cache tout sur
des propos polémiques ou des caprices
mais c'est vrai à l'heure elodie un jean
marie le pen s'en est pris à vous on y
reviendra mais vous étiez plusieurs a
tweeté louis aliot avait parlé aussi de
désaccords politiques irréconciliables
du strictement même chose qui est que
j'étais justement la même chirurgie
viable mais du coup vous étiez concerter
avant 7,8 c'était n'ont même pas n'ont
même pas oui s'il prouve qu'on a une
manière de voir les choses qui est quand
même assez semblables ce qui s'est
traduit dans l'ain d'ailleurs dans les
votes sur cette affaire au bureau
politique très très majoritaire pour
condamner les propos de jean marie le
pen est au bureau exécutif très très
majoritaires à une voix près pour
prendre la décision qui a été prise de
suspension d'accord donc vous vous
concerter pas là dessus et marine le pen
quand elle fait son communiqué a essayé
de vous twittez ou non je ne pense pas
d'ailleurs m'a jamais marine le pen ne
m'a reproché ce tweet ou ou quoi que ce
soit alors cela dit ce qu'a dit la
presse hama près bon voilà c'est la
presse mais c'est que c'est ça qui avait
vraiment entre guillemets braqué jean
marie le pen qui du coup après a été
très très dur et que voilà c'est ces
mots donc de vous rupture totale et
définitive c'est ça qu'il avait un peu
excédé et du coup est-ce que ça a pas
contribué quand même ajouter l'huile sur
le feu même si ça eu le mérite de
clarifier les choses avec les militants
de deux mètres jean marie le pen en
fureur
jean marie le pen était dans un état
d'esprit délétère bien avant il l'a été
après surprenait chrono
y'a aucune influence de ce tweet il
utilise maintenant ils communiquent
maintenant sur ce twitt mais il en a pas
parlé pendant trois semaines non ça n'a
rien à voir
l'huile sur le feu c'est pas nous qui l'
mettions c'est lui par ses déclarations
répétées ces déclarations qui était
voilà on va pas refaire l'histoire nous
dira aujourd'hui aujourd'hui pour nous
cette affaire c'est du passé
en tout cas ça savoura centre est
beaucoup dataxu sur vous effectivement à
edwards qui disent finalement il s'en
est pris particulièrement à vous pu
saquer louis aliot qui a tweeté la même
chose que vous parce qu'ils voient là il
s'est dit voilà florian philippot c'est
un point faible peut-être qu'il est
jaloux de votre influence auprès de
marine le pen ou d'autres relations avec
elle je sais pas vous avez une
explication sur je me suis interrogé je
sais pas peut-être qu'il a voulu surfer
sur l'idée qu'ils aient beaucoup écrite
de cette influence et c'est pour si vous
voulez arrêter cibler sa fille derrière
parce que moi je trouve que quand on dit
marine le pen est une marionnette et
c'est florian philippot le méchant qui
manigancent tout je pense que c'est
beaucoup plus insultant pour marine le
pen à la ford est en réalité ça permet
de développer une vieille rhétorique
d'extrême droite qui dit qu'une femme de
toute façon un poste de direction sera
toujours une cruche ou de marionnettes
et qu'elle pourra jamais rien décider
qui aura toujours un homme à côté pour
tirer les ficelles ça c'est une vieille
rhétorique d'extrême droite que vous
connaissez par coeur je pensais pas et
ça me navre que jean marie le pen tombe
là dedans mais après la biesme dit
qu'ils souhaitaient la défaite de sa
fille en 2017 il l'a répété récemment il
a même dit dans l affaire qui m'oppose
au qatar qu'il soutenait le qatar bon
voilà je suis longuement tout est dit
quoi oui mais voilà oui parce
qu'effectivement il ya eu des attaques
mutuelles le qatar 2 contre vous puisque
vous accusant dénigrer les cathares et
vous contre le qatar les questions de
catarman à l'expression et du centre
alsace pour dire ce que ce que beaucoup
de vos confrères ont déjà écrit le
courrier international écrit le qatar
c'est le club med des terroristes il ya
des rapports américains israéliens
français allemand qui disent tout cela
je les dis comme parlementaire ça fait
avancer le débat
le qatar dictature islamiste dictature
esclavagiste me poursuit en justice
c'est très grave honnêtement pour la
liberté d'expression en france
suite à cette colère de jean marie le
pen et à ses mots très durs à votre
égard et même beaucoup de journalistes
ont voulu vous faire réagir beaucoup
sont cassés les dents aussi il faut bien
le dire
je propose de revoir un extrait
commentée par jean pierre winter
philosophe et psychanalyste et
spécialiste du langage
voilà tout ça on se met sur le divan
avez-vous marabouté marine le pen vous
faites référence à une des expressions
fleuries de jean marie le pen c'est ça
bon déjà je vais pas si vous voulez en
quelques jours jean marie le pen a dit
qu'il répudier sa fille qu'il avait
honte qu'elle porte le même nom qui
souhaitait sa défaite en 2010 sept mois
il m'a agoni d'injures et d'insultés
depuis quelque 48 heures je j'ai une
indifférence totale vis-à-vis de ces
vous l'avez cherché non non je n'ai pas
cherché je pense pas non il parle de
vous et de vos mignon mais voilà bon ben
j'ai dit j'ai été agoni d'injures et
d'insultés assez nauséabondes
ne comptez pas sur moi pour y répondre
je considère que la politique c'est
autre chose
et encore une fois je vous le dit il
homophobe
vous avez forcément une réponse à cette
question non je trouve vos questions
assez indécente parce que je pars
question est inquiet parce que moi je
suis concernée par les insultez pas moi
qui tiens les anciens on vous pose la
question à celui qui tient les ensuite
voilà il refuse en aller sur le terrain
de l'émotion d'exprimer ses émotions des
domaines surtout il refuse surtout de
porter un jugement
c'est ça qui est le plus frappant c'est
à dire que il reçoit des insultes qui
sont manifestement homophobes
par quel miracle il est pas capable de
dire oui c'est homophobe il dit 6 et
homophobe
non il dit je ne sais pas il répond je
ne sais pas c'est sa renaissance et
homophobes ça rajoute mais c'est
homophobe je crois que personne ne
discute sur ce ce point qui n'est pas un
point de détail d'aups et c'est parti
c'est particulièrement insultant et il
prend une position de distance et voilà
il te regarde un peu les choses
de haut parce qu'il sait très bien que
s'ils portent une accusation trop
précises contre jean marie le pen il va
s'attirer les foudres d'une partie de du
front national qui n'est pas encore
prête à décrocher
donc il y va trés papa très
progressivement ce qui bon sur le plan
de tactique politique est peut-être très
habile mais qui en même temps révèle une
certaine tiédeur dans la capacité à
prendre position par des jugements ferme
et non discutable sur des points qui
aujourd'hui sont l'actualité voilà si
vous voulez alors c'est quand même c'est
impressionnant parce que c'est tout à
fait l'inversé de ce que vous venez de
me dit on me dit est ce que vous n'avez
pas été trop dur dans vos jugements dans
les mots vous avez employé
cela retire avec maintenant reproche au
sahel répondre à la victoire
non mais je suis moi clair et net et
parfois on dit trop dur non je suis
claire et nette sur le pont sur le du
point de vue politique
après les insultes de jean marie le pen
je veux dire n'importe qui de sensé qui
entend ces insultes a compris ce dont on
parle est bon est-ce que c'est homophobe
je pose la question ecoutez-le insultes
mais je vais pas jouer moi je veux pas
rentrer dans une guerre des mots avec
jean ça m'intéresse pas je veux pas
répondre jean marie le pen a éructé
injurié tout seul très bien il fera
d'ailleurs 70 procès au front national
comme il a commencé de le faire très
bien il aura personne pour lui répondre
on n'est pas à ce niveau là moi j'suis
pas leur cour de récréation je pense que
celui qui insulte et déshonoré c'est pas
celui qui reçoit d'insultés qui est
déshonoré moi je vois je veux revenir à
du terra terre mais depuis le début de
cette affaire un sondage bbr est sorti
chez les sympathisants front je gagne 13
points en un mois
d'accord ce qui prouve que nos
sympathisants et nos électeurs
n'apprécie pas eu non plus la cour de
récréation et je pense plutôt bien
d'ailleurs de récréation là on parle des
insultes homophobes et c'est pas la cour
de jerez que vous pouvez entendre dans
certaines cours de récréation elle est
généralement 6e 5e way n'a jamais comme
on dit donc vous dites en fait c'est pas
stratus effacé stratégique parce que
voulait pas jeter de l'huile sur le feu
c'est pas une peur d'aller défendre
certains n'ont pas du tout c'est pas
elle pas besoin de dire l'évidence voilà
avant les choses sont évidentes à sauter
donc il m'a agoni d'injures il
continuera très bien je sais pas
jusqu'où il ira ça ne s'est pas ménagé
les autres c'est pas pour ménager les
homophones en simple et en même temps et
je vous dis les sympathisants du front
les électeurs semblent suivre
il me donne plutôt raison et parce que
je pense que je suis dans la dignité de
la politique et c'est ma conception de
la politique tout simplement mais la
conception de mon engagement pour le
reste voilà on va pas pas besoin de
parfois de nommer l'évidence l'évidence
elle est évidente
au delà de ce qui nous pose à vous ça
pose effectivement ça peut poser
d'autres questions est ce que vous
n'avez pas peut-être l'impression que
d'autres auraient pu monter au créneau
au front national en disant enfin pas de
ce type d'insulté à son tour monté au
créneau non mais beaucoup beaucoup de
messages sans aucun problème sans aucun
problème que ce soit des gens que vous
connaissez les cadres ou marine le pen
en premier lieu qu'elle oscilla pas été
épargné par les insultes ou simplement
des combien je reçois chaque jour de
courriers de lettres d'adhérents de
militants qui sont affligés et et marion
maréchal-le pen à ce moment là elle a
été présente ou pas marion je la vois -
généralement donc qu'elles sont moins
présentes que marine n'est pas pas
aberrant parce que de manière générale
je vois dix fois plus marine que marion
mais c'est tout simple marine est ici on
travaille ensemble marion est à
l'assemblée nationale elle est en le
vaucluse
donc ça aide pas mais à la beauté bien
sûr en bureau politique
la condamnation des propos de jean marie
le pen elle l'a dit publiquement dans
des interviews bien sûr mais on a
l'impression qu'elle était plus tiède au
départ mais pour vous il va laver une
relation je pense qu'elle est en
relation plus proche
affectivement avec son grand père et
qu'il l'a lancé en politique dans le
vaucluse
ça me pensais que c'est pour ça qu'elle
a non mais tu comprendre pourquoi elle
s'était un peu mise à l'écart au départ
de sa candidature en paca dieu merci
j'en suis très heureux elle est revenue
sur sa décision est finalement allé tête
de liste comme elle a été investi par le
front en paca et je suis persuadé
qu'elle va gagner la région et je
l'espère en tout cas et alors il ya eu
des soutiens c'est ce que je commence à
dire effectivement bruno gollnisch marie
christine arnautu qui avait quand même
soutenu jean marie le pen qui ont été
écartés c'est la rupture avec eux la
rupture avec tous les gens du quartier
il n'y a pas de
mise à l'écart non ya pas de mise à
l'écart personnel ou quoique ce soit
d'autre à dire qu'ils sont soutenus
mollahs les gens qui ont soutenu jean
marie le pen ça peut paraître normal
qu'ils soient amusés les cas non parce
qu'il ya en même temps ils ont voté
christine a voté aussi la motion en
bureau politique bruno gollnisch aussi
donc un point de gagné la bottine il me
sembla motion en bureau politique
oui marie christine c'est sûr tout a en
tout cas il a exprimé ils ont exprimé
clairement aussi leur désaccord sur le
fond c'est ce qui compte c'est ce qui
compte
après qu'ils un combat commun et jean
marie le pen l'ancien on va pas leur
enlever on va pas leur retirer ça reste
c'est comme ça quand vous demandez pas
aux jambes certainement on a dit que
vous étiez jeune vous avez plein de
plein de choses devant vous vous voyez
ou dans dix ans on sera quand en 2025
on sera au coeur du deuxième mandat de
marine le pen
ah oui vous y croyez vraiment ah bah oui
sinon je serais pas là si j'y croyais
pas et ce sera son dernier mandat
d'ailleurs puisque ce sera le le
septennat qui aura été rétablie non mais
j'espère qu'à ce moment là effectivement
ce n'est pas une plaisanterie j'espère
qu'on serait en train de se battre à des
postes exécutifs pour la france et qu'on
sera entre 1 et qu'on aura déjà dans dix
ans largement entamé le redressement
national
il y en a plus que besoin maintenant on
va pas laisser les mêmes de gros partis
de droite et de gauche qui sont pouvoir
être ça risque de prendre plus de temps
que ça va vous êtes impatients non mais
ça va je pense que l'arrivée au pouvoir
peut être rapide
je pense qu'elle peut vraiment être
rapide maintenant vous savez quand vous
arrivez à des niveaux de présidentielle
second tour 42 45 52 % des récentes
enquêtes quand vous voyez qu'on est
premier parti de france
willard heures la dynamique patriotes ça
peut aller très très vite il faut que ça
aille vite
la france va par confier les clés à des
gens qui sont là depuis 30 ans ou des
partis qui se partagent le pouvoir
depuis 30 ans à votre ambition ailleurs
à la fin c'est un très bon mari bon run
vous ferez quoi vous serez premier
ministre non mais sur le redressement
on va tous se retrousser les manches
toute la nation tout entière et la
france dans les grands moments de son
histoire peut faire des grandes choses
très rapidement et ne sera pas facile
mais ça peut être ça peut te rapide
d'accords dans 10 ans fin du deuxième
mandat vous dites un de marine le pen et
vous quoi leur premier ministre ah bah
je serais ce que la présidence de la
république on aura décidé vous
connaissez la constitution française
aussi bien que moi d'accord on est un
poste exécutif gelé
c'est là que je me sens plus utile quand
vous êtes optimiste bah je suis
optimiste
oui j'suis nature optimiste pour le
combat auquel je crois pour la france
parce que je vois encore une fois plein
de signes pour l'être et en même temps
je sais l'état de gravité dans lequel se
trouve notre pays ça ça me fait mal ça
me fait très mal
d'accord merci beaucoup florian film
poser la barre participer à cette
émission va vous être un petit peu un
petit peu vous avez raison on a envie de
les abîmer
j'ai pas passé le dernier magnéto c'est
quoi un moment de la manif pour tous est
ce pas là la vie' conseil à marine le
pen de périodes pas y participer et
c'est c'était vrai mais alors vous avez
ouais je sais donc voilà aussi on était
sur la même longueur d'onde